[Music]
a common assumption is that all white
sugar is derived from sugar cane
but 30 percent of the world's white
sugar supply comes from the sugar beet
while sugarcane grows only in tropical
climates the heartier sugar beet can be
cultivated in cooler regions and in
poorer soil
it takes about seven beets to produce a
little more than two pounds of sugar
the byproducts of processing molasses
and beet pulp are used for animal feed
the processing of sugar beets yields
various grades of sugar the lower ones
are reprocessed to become white sugar
farmers plant beet seeds in the spring
and harvest the mature crop in the fall
mechanical harvesters attack six rows at
a time they rip the plant out of the
ground chop off the leaves and crown
leaving just the bulbous root
a beetroot typically weighs about two
pounds
seventeen to eighteen percent of that is
sucrose which is sugar
a loader transfers the harvested beets
into trucks
the loader sieve removes about a third
of the soil along the way
[Music]
when the trucks arrive at the sugar
factory they unload the beets soil and
stones included onto a conveyor belt
which transports them to a washing
station
first they head into a revolving drum
where under a shower of water the beets
rub against each other dislodging the
soil
the water flow floats the beets which
then exit the drum
the stones stay behind collected in
separator buckets along the edge
a screw conveyor moves the beets to a
transfer system which brings them inside
the factory to be processed into sugar
inside slicing machines cut the incoming
beets into cassettes
strips about the shape of french fries
but smaller
the cassettes travel on a conveyor belt
into a large tank of hot water where
they soak for a few minutes
this gets their cell membranes to begin
opening clearing the way for the sucrose
to exit during the next operation in
which the cassettes are pumped to the
bottom of a 22-yard high extraction
tower
a rotating shaft within the tower
transports them slowly upward against
the downward flow of hot water
this draws out the sucrose producing a
sugary water called raw juice
the next step is to purify this raw
juice in a giant kiln they burn
limestone with coke to produce the
chemical compound calcium hydroxide also
called lime milk they added in several
stages to the raw juice
meanwhile they press the sucrose strip
cassettes into pulp to sell as animal
feed
they add carbon dioxide to the lime milk
and juice mixture this absorbs one third
of the juice's impurities enabling a
filtration system to remove them
the raw juice exits as a golden sugar
solution called thin juice
the thin juice then enters a six step
evaporation process which reduces it to
a thick syrup-like juice
from there they pump it into a
four-phase crystallization system
in phase one they heat and add seed
crystals tiny identical size sugar
crystals made separately using a complex
cooling and evaporating process
as the water in the juice evaporates
about half of the sucrose crystallizes
growing the seed crystals
then a centrifuge machine separates the
crystals called refined sugar from the
remaining syrup
the syrup goes through this
crystallization centrifuge process three
more times producing a lesser grade of
sugar each time
the factory dissolves and recrystallizes
the lowest two grades
the highest grades of sugar go into
dryers
on the way passing through a screening
machine which separates any crystals
which are too large
the factory dissolves these crystals
then puts the sugary liquid through the
crystallization process again
so in the end there are two grades of
beet sugar which go into silos where
they're stored until it's time to
package them for sale as refined sugar
and white sugar
you